foreign
[Music]
here are all the 30 Predator weapons in
order of appearance in movies
chronologically these are pretty badass
Tech if you ask me let's take a look
guys
firstly the biomask as well as
performing the basic function of
protecting a predator's head the helmet
also grounds the wearer access to
multiple Vision modes including zoom
capabilities facilitates vocal mimicry
and includes breathing apparatus
Diagnostics and visual and audio
recording systems
secondly the cloak also known as the
invisibility system the chameleon field
or the shift suit it is an advanced
piece of the outjet technology that is
able to render the user invisible are
nearly invisible to the naked eye number
three the wrist blades they are the most
basic of viaja weapons and arguably the
signature Armament of their species the
blades take the form of retractable
surreal blades between 6 and 18 inches
long that come out of the wrist
gauntlets
number four there is gauntlets also
known as the wrist bracer or the wrist
computer it is a piece of wrist worn
yaji technology that houses several
technologically advanced features
including a satcom and a powerful
self-destruct device
number five the mini nuke this is a very
powerful liaoja explosive device built
into the Predator risk Gauntlet this
weapon is a last resort and it is used
by the yaja both as a means to which to
commit honorable suicide in the face of
an imminent defeat and to erase all
traits of that Predator from that
ecosystem
number six the plasma Caster this is a
long-range energy projector weapon with
automatic targeting capabilities capable
of firing armor penetrating plasma balls
at distant targets it is arguably the
most devastating and technologically
advanced offensive tool wielded by the
Predators
number seven the spear gun this is a
projectile weapon that launches a spike
of razor sharp metal at a Target and
these projectiles are fast moving and
are often launched with enough Force to
shatter Stone
number eight the combi stick also known
as the telescoping spear it is a
spear-like yowger weapon which is
telescopic making it relatively small
and easy to store when not in use but
can be extended to its full length when
required in combat
number nine the net gun also known as
the net launcher it is a weapon that
fires a wire net at a great velocity and
with Great Falls to trap in and snare
prey once fired the net itself has the
ability to tighten around its trap
Target with sufficient Force to cause
the mesh to cut through the victim into
pieces
number 10 the smart disc also known as
the smart weapon a cutting disc or
simply the disc it is a primarily thrown
the audio weapon arranged one and it is
extremely sharp and circular cutting
device that is typically thrown like a
discus throw yet returns to the user
like a boomerang
number 11 the energy fleshette it is a
yard shot range energy projector weapon
in many respects it is a simpler less
powerful version of the plasma Caster
built into the yacht just risk gauntlet
number 12 the Predator sword known as
the haside in yaja language it is a
weapon occasionally carried and used by
a yaoja in Warfare it is seen being held
by the Elder Predator from the second
movie
13 the Plasma Pistol also known as a
plasma handgun it is a handheld version
of the yaja plasma Caster while
purpose-built examples are known to
exist the weapon can also be assembled
in the field from a novel plasma cast
that was installed in the shoulder
number 14 the whip also known as the
razor whip it is a fast moving out your
weapon a segmented handheld bull whip
that wraps around a Target and once
pulled it is capable of cutting the
Target in half
number 15 the flaying tool it is a
y-shaped tool meant to be grabbed at the
bottom and emits a laser from between
its prongs that is hot enough to burn
and easily peel skin off a prey species
for trophies
number 16 the solvent this dissolving
liquid was a highly potent corrosive
blue chemical used by the yowja which
dissolves any piece of organic material
it was placed on including Xenomorphs
carcasses and turn them into a pile of
goop
number 17 the Predator mines also known
as proximity mines or throwing mines
they are various types of mind-based
weapery used by the Predators on their
hunts the aesthetic weapons triggered
when an enemy passes close by either
automatically or remotely
number 18 the shuriken it is a primarily
thrown yaja weapon constructed with six
retractable blades it is sharp enough to
cut through three inches of solid stone
or cut a xenomoth in half
number 19 the hellhound slash Predator
dogs these are by weapons that would
Genetically Enhanced and bred to be like
hunting dogs able to track down prey
immobilize and even kill them there were
two types of species of these kind of
dogs the hellhounds of the super
predators and the Predator dogs of the
upgrade predator
number 20 the Scimitar also known as the
arm blade it is a metallic bladed yauja
weapon used on their hunts while similar
to wrist blades and function scimitars
are often greatly increased in range
owing to their greater size but at a
cost of increased bulk and reduced
maneuverability
number 21 the Falcon this was a
bird-like spine device used by a super
Predator called the falconer on the game
preserved Planet the Falcon's role it's
like a drone and was meant to watch over
the prey to study them and their tactics
22 that this integrated gas this was
seen in the new movie prey and was a
type of gas used by the yaja the feral
Predator to decompose any organic
remains of the victim's head with the
exception of their skulls
23 the laser guided bulbs a variant of
the spear gun wielded by the feral
Predator the bolt gun had guided bolts
that sought out their target via the use
of a biomass targeting laser system not
unlike a plasma caster
24 the cut clamp this weapon can change
shape allowing them to wrap around
objects or to be thrown like a solid
dagger these are new weapons for this
Predator variant in the franchise
although other bladed weapons are stable
of their Arsenal
25 The Shield this is a Deployable
device attached to the gauntlet it is
small but durable and easily retractable
when not in use the device was able to
withstand both blunt force bladed
weapons and even bullets from muskets
and pistols it could also be used
offensively to cut through things
26 the laser disc these spinning and
hovering just come out from The Gauntlet
and produce lasers that seemingly cut
through anything in their path killing
their French Trappers and cutting down
some trees in the process
27 the res Canon this is an energy
projected weapon which in many respects
is a stronger version of the energy
fleshette and was built into the Yao
just risk Gauntlet it is essentially a
strong plasma weapon that is installed
on the risk gauntlet
28 their Predator killer this is a full
body armor designed for humans by the
Predators and was made to look like one
including the dreadlocks on each
shoulder are three plasmicasters with
independent targeting systems and a
Giant Cannon it also comes with wrist
blades that are longer which might be
scimitars
29 the Predator Scout ship these are
small spaceships that are used by the
Predators as transport for either a
single hunter or a small pack they are
super fast capable of interstellar
travel as in the case of AVP requiem's
world's ship and is also packed with
plasma cannons as well as missiles
and lastly the Predator Mothership these
are Big spaceships of the Predators and
are used as mobile bases for clans on
off world missions these motherships can
carry several Scout ships within them
and are armed with plasma beams missiles
as well as cloaking technology and also
they have a lot of predators which means
a lot of weapons
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video on the 30 Predator weapons that
have been seen in movies do you hear the
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam